hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about the oxidase test so first
before we talk about the procedure of
the oxidase test let's talk about some
of the background theory there is an
enzyme known as cytochrome C oxidase and
it is a really important enzyme in
aerobic respiration and that is because
it accepts electrons as part of the
electron transport chain
the oxidase test tests for the presence
of cytochrome C oxidase
so the oxidase test uses this compound
called tetra methyl P phenol named
diamine here's a picture of it right
here it's commonly abbreviated as TMP d
so this comes from tetra methyl p phenol
in diamine
if you've got some organic chemistry
background you know that tetra methyl
refers to four methyl groups those are
these four ch3 groups the diamine is
referring to the two nitrogen components
and then the the P here is referring to
the fact that they're on opposite sides
of this benzene ring those where we get
that name
and so this TMP D serves as an
artificial electron donor so basically
something that can donate electrons to
this cytochrome C oxidase and so what
ends up happening is that the TMP D can
change color so what it does is it has
electrons that it can donate to
cytochrome C oxidase and when it donates
those electrons it is
so in other words when an electron is
removed here you've got loss of an
electron that equals oxidation so it's
being oxidized the cytochrome C oxidase
is doing the oxidizing it's gaining the
electron so it's becoming reduced if you
remember your redox reactions there and
so TMP D goes from being colorless when
it has all of its electrons to turning
into a blue purple color so sort of a
bluish purplish color is what will
happen once it's oxidized and it's only
oxidized when oxidase is present to take
that to take those electrons so if we
have a color change in the oxidase test
from colorless to blue purple that means
oxidase positive in other words that
means as the bacterium is oxidase
positive it produces cytochrome C
oxidase some examples of oxidase
positive bacteria are super bonus and
the Syria both of these kinds but both
of these types of bacteria have various
implications for human disease and so
that makes the oxidase test an important
diagnostic tool to help doctors
understand when a patient is infected
with these kinds of bacteria so now
let's talk about the procedure for the
oxidase test you add the test solution
the t MPD to a slide and then transfer a
colony from an auger plate into this t
MPD if that bacteria that's in that
colony is oxidase positive then you're
going to see a really rapid color change
from colorless to sort of a blue or a
purple color and this color change is
very quick five to ten seconds and that
indicates the presence of oxidase and so
that's an oxidase positive result if the
TM PD remains colorless then it would be
oxidase negative a couple of things to
keep in mind you want to do this step
here transferring a colony from the
auger plate to the TM PD do that with
like a sterile wooden stick or a sterile
plastic loop not something that contains
iron so a wire loop a metal loop is
going to contain iron that can give a
false positive use of old reagents and
also use of auger plates that have
certain dyes and them can sometimes also
give false positives so it's important
that you make sure that you're using the
right kinds of equipment when you're
doing the oxidized test if you're
interested in my other videos you can
check out my video on a catalyzed test
which is another important diagnostic
tool to test for the presence of
catalase if you want to learn more about
enzymes like oxidase and catalase you
can check out my video on introduction
to enzymes and if you want to learn more
about aerobic respiration in this
electron transport chain then you can
check out my video on aerobic
respiration but that's it for today
thanks for watching biology professor